did you see
oh my gosh did you see the Forbes
Women's Summit you could not make this
up the Babylon B could not do a
satirical article about this
Forbes held a Women's Summit
and the Women's Summit invited women's
rights advocates
into online
influencers and all sorts of you know
all sorts of big women and one of the
one of the women that the Forbes Women's
Summit invited is a guy named Dylan
Mulvaney who is a guy who thinks that
he's a woman and he's come to some
prominence on Tick Tock for his days of
girlhood series
this this is the guy that they invited
to personify to exemplify the very best
of women
day 66 being a girl and today I'm in
nature
trees I love them
water lakes I love them
heels they're my hiking heels I love
them
Bridges love them
coconut water love it not mad just love
it
wind turbine love it Meadows love them
[Music]
love ya
oh
did you see that I gotta get out of here
did you see that there's a dragonfly oh
my God never again get me out of here
love you that's just what women are like
right this man prancing around in booty
Shores with a little bra on playing up
this extremely fopish face sort of fear
of a little bug and flitting about and
throwing himself on the ground that's
just what women are like right isn't
that what women are like no not at all
that's it there's an adult owner like
that's what men with a bizarre sexual
fetisher like
there's a there's another he's
explaining what it's like to to be
him he's explaining the the absolute
horror that some people would believe
that he's actually a man
day 62 of being a girl and I have been
misgendered so many times this week and
most commonly it's a follower running up
to me on the street and being like
you're the boy from Tick Tock it's the
boy from Tick Tock and I'm like no it's
it's the girl from Tick Tock and they
always feel so bad after I correct them
and that's so not my intention it
doesn't hurt my feelings all that much
but I wear all this makeup and sometimes
fake boobs in the hair and it still
doesn't register with people at times
and I was just wondering if there's
anything I can do on my end for you all
to see me more as a girl I know it's not
my job I was just curious
no there's absolutely nothing you can do
could you believe it could you believe
that some people would think that guy is
a man that guy he says look I I dress up
like a Betty Boop caricature of what
some man might think a woman at her most
absolutely absurd
caricature could be and some people
still think that I'm a man could you
imagine that could you possibly imagine
that okay and I know it's not my job to
show people that I'm really a woman but
of course he's not really a woman and
the things he's doing are extremely
absurd and disordered and ridiculous and
we wouldn't tolerate it from any other
person it reminds me of Family Guy that
voice crying out in the Wilderness
Family Guy which explains this
phenomenon excuse me ma'am no porn at
the bar oh it's okay I'm transgender oh
I I had no idea do whatever you want all
the time
I no no it's uh sir you don't understand
I'm allowed to do absolutely anything
whatsoever because I'm saying I'm
transgender and what does society say oh
yes yes of course
this guy who shows up to the Forbes
Women's Summit dressed up like some
ridiculous caricature of a woman and
flitting about and and
mocking women and making a whole mockery
of the concept of Womanhood
how do we deal with this
the way that conservatives are dealing
with this now is we're saying you're
you're not really a woman a boom owned
with facts and logic you have a a strong
jawline sir and you don't have the body
parts of a woman and you're not boom own
science
but that that's not enough you know what
that guy's gonna say he's going to say f
your science who cares I don't care
about your stupid science take your
science and shove it I'm gonna dress up
like a lady because I say I'm a lady and
you can't stop me who's gonna stop me
and this is where we get to what the
real conservative response has to be who
cares who cares if I'm dressing up like
a woman
me
I care
who's going to stop me from dressing up
like a woman and behaving this way
I guess I guess I can't speak for you
I'll just speak for myself
me I would verily very happily stop you
from doing that I think that you sir
and all men out there have an obligation
not to behave that way
you have an obligation not to go outside
in little booty shorts and a bra and and
a big silly wig and lipstick and and
pretend to be a woman
you
I care I don't want you to do that I am
willing to wield the force of culture
and standards and norms and the state to
stop you from doing that
that's the conservative response that's
the only way you're going to stop it
you're not going to stop it by winning
some debate on YouTube or tick tock
you're not going to stop it by showing
someone some statistics and and citing
some stupid data set about chromosomes
okay you're going to win it by pointing
out that whatever bizarre perversions
are going on in this dude's head he has
a duty and an obligation not to express
them certainly not to express them in
public and then the only other way
you're going to win it is by wielding
political power to say no you don't get
to do it
when you go out in public like this
you you have to be brought to
psychological counseling if you continue
to behave like this you're going to be
committed to an institution this kind of
behavior is obscene I'm thinking of that
shop teacher who showed up to class in
Canada with the gigantic triple Z
prosthetic breasts and the wig on
looking like a complete maniac
the only way you're going to stop it is
if if you have the courage to wield
political power to say no you don't get
to behave like a crazy person why do I
care you know why I care because I live
in society and I don't want my kids to
grow up in this kind of degenerate
society and I don't want to live in this
kind of Bizarro World absurd Society I
want to live in a nice good place with
good true and beautiful things around me
and people acting as they should and
being polite and being normal be normal
come on folks good grief is it so much
to ask
that we live in a society that is normal
because this is becoming normal and I
don't want to live in that normal I
don't want to live in The New Normal
okay I want to live in a
in a good traditional Society it's not
so much to ask I don't think it is so
how do you get to that Society what's
the basis of that Society
the answer is Christianity this was the
topic of my speech last night the speech
was on our far right semi-fascist
radical extreme founding fathers in the
way that our country existed until about
five minutes ago
but the basis of that Society is
Christianity I'm so glad you like that
clip now you gotta ring that Bell Smash
It bang it bop it pop it we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]